unser verhältnis zu russland ist vertrag
wir brauchen russisches gas und unseren
energiebedarf zu decken
genau dafür wird die ostseepipeline nord
stream 2 gebaut
das projekt mit dem russischen
staatskonzern gazprom ist aber seit
langem umstritten und führt zu ärger mit
den usa und auch das europäische
parlament will einen baustopp und druck
auf russland auszuüben
gefordert wird die freilassung des
kreml-kritikers alexej nawalny der nach
seiner rückreise aus deutschland direkt
verhaftet worden
am wochenende wurde in vielen russischen
städten gegen putin demonstriert 3500
menschen wurden festgenommen
streiten derweil nie und nordring wie
umgehen mit russland unser thema in der
phoenix runde
[Musik]
schönen guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin ja reden wir über
russland mit abgeordneten des deutschen
bundestages hier im studio begrüße ich
johann saathoff von der spd er ist seit
august 2020 koordinator für die
zwischengesellschaftliche zusammenarbeit
mit russland zentralasien und den
ländern der östlichen partnerschaft sei
ein sehr bodenständiger wahlkreis liegt
in emden aurich und herzlich willkommen
franziska brantner von bündnis 90 die
grünen sie ist sprecherin für
europapolitik und parlamentarische
geschäftsführerin der bundestagsfraktion
und vor ihrer zeit im bundestag war sie
mitglied im europaparlament zugeschaltet
ist uns findet für die cdu der
außenpolitische sprecher der
bundestagsfraktion jürgen hardt schönen
guten abend herr hart er war vorher
koordinator für die transatlantische
zusammenarbeit und ich begrüße es sehr
windelen von der linken sie ist
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
fraktion sprecherin für internationale
beziehungen und für abrüstungspolitik
schönen guten abend forderte er sagt
wenn wir jetzt nord stream zwei stoppen
einige fordern das ja auch im
europäischen parlament gibt seit langem
darüber eine diskussion würde das helfen
damit alexej nawalny frei kommt das
bezweifle ich stark
ich finde auch dass wenn wir über nord
stream zwei sprechen
das nicht unbedingt verbinden müssen mit
einem fall wir wollen aber auch nicht
mit anderen fällen die das fordern
da fällt schon auf dass diejenigen sind
die vor zwei drei jahren auch nicht fan
der leitung waren
ich bin zuständig für die
zwischengesellschaftliche zusammenarbeit
dazu gehört auch die wirtschaft ich muss
brücken und verbindungen bauen möchte
das gerne unterstützen
und ich glaube dass es wichtig ist dass
wir verbindungen nicht kappen dass wir
schon dinge die nicht in ordnung sind
auch ansprechen auch in aller
deutlichkeit ansprechen am besten auch
in einem internationalen europäischen
kontext aber nicht dass wir deswegen
gleich sozusagen dann sämtliche
verbindungen abreißen würde wenn wir nur
zwei nicht zu ende bauen nicht ein
molekül weniger methan nach deutschland
geraten aber ansprechen alleine im fall
navalny hat ja bisher nicht gereicht die
kritik von deutschland ist ja sehr stark
und von der europäischen politik auch
die kritik an den festnahmen
bei den protesten am wochenende also das
reicht ja doch nicht
das ist die frage ob dialog reicht oder
nicht reicht es sind dicke bretter die
wir zu bohren haben und es dort eine
sehr sehr schwierige zeit aus meiner
sicht und es hilft aus meiner sicht nur
dialog also ich halte nichts davon wenn
man jetzt über starke plakative
maßnahmen politische handlungsfähigkeit
simuliert sondern ich bin ein freund
davon dass menschen sich begegnen das
sie mit anderen dinge erarbeiten dass
sie sich etwas kann man nicht begegnen
ersetzen haft naja aber die
zivilgesellschaftlichen organisationen
kann man begegnen und das zu
unterstützen zwischen russland und
deutschland unter anderem russland und
deutschland das ist meine aufgabe als
koordinator ok frau brandner wie sehen
sie ihre partei chefin annalena baerbock
hat ganz klar gesagt wir brauchen einen
baustopp für nordring um den druck zu
erhöhen
da hat sie auch absolut recht wir
brauchen jetzt endlich den baustopp von
diesem projekt das schon sehr lange
falsch ist oder es ist ein
prestige-projekt von putin und es kann
nicht angehen dass wir in einer
situation wo wirklicher viele menschen
sehr mutig in russland auf die straße
gehen daraufhin sehr viele verhaftet
werden menschen in haft sitzen ohne eine
rechtsstaatliche grundlage dafür dass
wir nur schöne worte finden und wir
müssen das kalkül von putin mit
beeinflussen können es kann nicht sein
dass wir kritik äußern und uns dann ins
bett legen mit seinen oligarchen die ihm
sein system finanzieren
das ist nicht glaubwürdig aber glauben
sie das würde wirklich helfen wenn man
sagen würde man stoppt das projekt und
dann würde man damit der demokratie
demokratiebewegung in russland oder den
den demonstranten helfen und auch alexej
nawalny dadurch frei bekommen ob das
sofort morgen dieses ergebnis liefert
das werden wir sehen aber es ist wichtig
dass wir das das machtkalkül auch bei
putin und seiner clique mit beeinflussen
können und wenn putin menschen versucht
umzubringen wenn er sie danach wenn sie
zurückkommen einfach wieder in haft
nimmt auf grundlage eines urteils was
der europäische menschengerichtshof als
eindeutig politisch beurteilt hat wenn
wir dann einfach zur tagesordnung
weitergehen und gar nichts tun dann
merkt sie dass putin und beim nächsten
mal geht noch einen schritt weiter und
beim nächsten mal bringt er den dann
wirklich um und deswegen ist es wichtig
auch zu sagen es gibt prestige-projekte
es gibt den ostring projektes finanziert
das umfeld und das korrupte system putin
und da an diesem system fest zu
halten dass es in dieser situation
wirklich falsch er hat wie sehen sie es
kann man eigentlich dieses projekt jetzt
noch stoppen und welche folgen hätte das
zunächst einmal möchte ich feststellen
dass die debatte über dieses projekt mit
unseren europäischen partnern aber auch
mit den amerikanern von anfang an völlig
schief gelaufen ist weil uns von außen
keine abgenommen hat dass wir dieses
projekt aus energiepolitischen und
außenpolitischen gründen für richtig
halten könnten
weil jeder gesagt hat ein ehemaliger
deutscher bundeskanzler verbindet mit
gazprom mit der russischen staats
wirtschaft seine politik seine
wirtschaftliche zukunft und deswegen
waren alle unsere argumente belastet mit
diesen vorwurf der meines erachtens auch
eine schwere hypothek ist und das ist
eines der gravierendsten probleme finde
ich dass ein ehemaliger deutscher
bundeskanzler sich dieser art und weise
weiter engagiert nachfrage er hat das
heißt wenn gerhard schröder dann nicht
engagiert wäre dann gäbe es keine
probleme damit
ich glaube wir hätten dann eher die
chance gehabt mit unseren partnern in
europa und in amerika darüber zu reden
ob und in welcher weise weil diese
leitung braucht jetzt ist sie fast
fertig sie wird von privaten unternehmen
finanziert ich glaube sie ist ökonomisch
ein flop ich stimme den grünen insofern
zu als dass ich glaube dass die nord
stream zwei leitung überhaupt jemals
gebraucht werden wird weil sich die
entwicklung der gasnachfrage in den
nächsten jahren eben doch anders
entwickelt als man das vor 10 15 jahren
vorhergesagt hat und das wäre ja ein
absoluter treppenwitz wenn wir jetzt
durch gesetz dieses projekt verbieten
würden dann möglicherweise
schadensersatzpflichtig werden würden
gegenüber unternehmen die aus eigenem
unternehmerischen kalkül aus eigenem
risiko in das projekt eingegangen sind
und dann von uns auch noch dafür
entschädigt werden dass sie dieses
wirtschaftliche risiko von der backe
haben
hinter vorgehaltener hand kann ich mir
vorstellen wäre der eine oder andere an
ostern zwei beteiligten froh wenn es zu
dieser lösung dieses problems geben ich
glaube die leitung wirklich gebraucht
und wir müssen in europa darüber
diskutieren wie viel gas wie viel
russisches gas können wir im sinne von
energie unabhängigkeit im europäischen
gasnetz
ertragen und vertragen und der spielt
frage habt jetzt über nord sind zwei
oder drei kilo das herkommt erst eine
nachgeordnete ok frau darin wie ihre
bewertung gerne was sagen sie wie
sinnvoll wäre es diese an dieser
pipeline festzuhalten wenn wir bekommen
40 prozent unseres gases kommt aus
russland brauchen wir diese treppen und
macht es sinn sie jetzt ja hat in diesen
baustopp zu fordern um eben druck
auszuüben auf russland also zunächst
einmal plädiere ich dafür die themen
voneinander zu trennen
wir haben einmal den fall von neuwahlen
hie und da ist ein furchtbares
verbrechen geschehen das muss aufgeklärt
werden
die verantwortlichen müssen zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden das muss
geahndet und auch geächtet werden
das ist klar aber ich warne davor
navalny zusammen zu setzen oder in
zusammenhang mit nord stream zwei zu
setzen
und ich finde es auch unseriös muss ich
sagen dass diejenigen die sowieso schon
immer nämlich die usa us amerikanische
unternehmen die ein großes interesse
haben richtiges um welches und teurere
fracking gas nach europa zu bringen nach
dort anzubringen schon immer dagegen
waren sturm gelaufen sind auch mit
sanktionen bedroht haben und auch
sanktionen verhängt haben dass die jetzt
ein solches verbrechen ausnutzen um ihre
forderung nach einem stopp von nord
stream zwei sozusagen zu befeuern
nord stream 2 und das muss ich auch
sagen aus trier 2 ist eben nicht nur ein
projekt zwischen deutschland und
russland und das prestige projekt von
herrn putin sondern es ist ein projekt
wo über 100 unternehmen aus 12
europäischen ländern beteiligt sind nur
ungefähr zwölf milliarden euro schon
investiert worden sind
die hälfte aus deutschland und es ist
ein gemeinschaftsprojekt was von
deutschland genehmigt wurden es von eben
behörden genehmigt worden ist und wir
brauchen auch aus gründen der
energieversorgung und der
energiesicherheit
die brückentechnologie nord stream 2 und
wenn ich mir jetzt anschaue
also da diejenigen die jetzt aus
ökologischen gründen gegen nostrum zwei
argumentieren die alternative ist
französische atomstrom tschechischer
atomstrom dreckiges fracking gas aus den
usa oder autokraten pipelines aus
turkmenistan oder aserbaidschan okay
also sie sagen sie sagen wirtschaft
ökologisch und energiepolitischen inwent
brauchen bilder aus rechtlicher sicht
dagegen argumentiert dann müssen wir
diese maßstäbe diese prinzipien überall
anwenden wir beziehen nach rohstoffe was
autokratien und diktaturen wie saudi
arabien dann ist mir auch noch okay sie
sind menschenrechten aufhören rohstoffe
zu beliefert zu correa sie plädieren für
eine klare trennung von beiden themen
sagen und das ist ja auch mal das
argument verbrannten aber es immer
genannt wurde dass das nord stream zwei
das ist einfach ein rein
privatwirtschaftliches unternehmen ist
und dass das eben zu trennen ist von der
politik ja das ist eines dieser immer
wieder kursierenden gerüchte dass
energiepolitik nicht politisch sein und
dabei ist energiepolitik hochpolitisch
sicherheitspolitisches hat ganz viele
komponenten und frau dagdelen wenn sie
jetzt sagen die dagegen sind die sind ja
eigentlich nur die vasallen der
amerikaner da kann ich nur knallhart
sagen wir haben die us-sanktionen von
anfang an kritisiert und nur weil man
gegen das eine ist ist man noch längst
nicht für das andere
wir sind gegen beides gegen us fracking
gas und gegen moslem 2 und mit blick auf
die wirtschaftlichkeit wenn wir da
bleiben wollen das bundes wird
vermutlich regierung hat vorgerechnet
dass wir bis 2030 weniger gasimporte
brauchen um bis 2040 drastisch weniger
deutsche institut der wirtschaft es gibt
zig studien wissenschaftliche dienst des
bundestages hat mit übersicht aller
studien gemacht der bundestag hat das
gemacht wissenschaftliche dienst und es
gibt eine studie sagt wir brauchen mehr
gas und das ist finanziert von gazprom
und wenn sie mir beim heer hart wenn sie
versuchen das einfach nur auf denen
gerhard schröder die spd abzuschieben
das ist auch echt nicht korrekt weil
diese bundesregierung trägt diese
pipeline und die europäischen partner
die haben ihren widerspruch eingelegt
nicht wegen gerhard schröder sondern
wegen dem projekt und das ist eben ein
anti europäisches projekt weil es weder
die bald noch die skandinavier noch die
europäer ihre
jemanden ernst nimmt und so tut als ob
das nichts mit ihnen zu tun hätte das
einfach antieuropäisch heute an sie
wollten kurz widersprechen und dann ist
da noch dran
da würde ich gern kurz merklich anderen
wenn man doch tatsächlich gegen us
fracking glas ist was tolles was
umweltschädlicher ist weil uns weil es
beim transport natürlich auch noch
höhere co2 emissionen
jetzt möchte ich doch wissen warum die
grünen die in der landesregierung in
schleswig holstein sind hier fracking
gas terminals anbauen also den ausbau
damit betreiben damit fracking gas aus
den usa eben hierher transportiert
werden kann
ich habe bisher keine klare politik
erkennen okay bin ich glaube die wollen
wir jetzt über fächer können weiß nicht
das ist glaube ich noch mal ein anderes
thema ich würde mich ganz gerne mal bei
einer sache bleiben die erhard
angesprochen hat und da muss ich doch
noch den spd abgeordneten zu fragen er
hat ganz klar gesagt das problem ist
dass gerhard schröder als ehemalige
bundeskanzler sich da so für dieses
projekt einsetzt ist das problem
also ehrlich gesagt die argumentation
für mich zu kurz getragen es gibt gute
gründe für den nord stream zwei
verbrannten es ist so dass es institute
gibt die sagen wir hätten den bedarf an
erdgas gar nicht gibt auch andere
institute die das genau anders sehen
dazu und ich würde mal sagen über allen
wenn man alle institute dass ich mal
anguckt dann stellt man fest dass die
reifen sagen wir lernen bis 2030 einen
höheren gasbedarf haben und ab 2035
einen niedrigeren es ist so frau klaan
wir steigen aus aus kohle wir steigen
aus der atomenergie und wer die
energiewende will und das verantwortlich
gestalten will bis 2050 der muss auch
ein backup haben oder wie wir ihn aus
friesland sagen hände später aus bogen
also zu haben ist es besser als
irgendwann nochmal zu benötigen und
deswegen ist diese leitung sinnvoll im
übrigens ist in einem europäischen
kontext zu bewerten
kein mensch kann im moment hochrechnen
wie denn der bedarf an gas oder
energiebedarf generalisiert in ganz
europa sein und wurden an dieser leitung
er wählte auch für wasserstoff nutzen
können das ist die zukunft angeht
gerne trotzdem auf diesen punkt herr
sato weil sie es eigentlich besser
wissen müssten sie kommen auch aus der
klimapolitik die berechnungen sind da
sehr klar das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium hat einen
geringeren bedarf an gas vorhergesehen
alle institute wissenschaftliche dienst
des bundestages hat alle studien die es
dazu gibt überprüft alle aufgelistet und
da gibt es nur eine die sagt wir werden
mehr gas brauchen und das ist die von
gazprom finanziert alle anderen seien
gewertet ich habe das interessant dass
die das wirtschaftsministerium
es ist ja eben kein grüner finken
sondern das wirtschaftsministerium wir
brauchen richtig ein auch dass das
wirtschaftsministerium antizipiert sind
die grünen genau dagegen da sagen sie
das ist viel zu niedrig antizipiert beim
gasverbrauch sind sie da einen
einverstanden
agora energiewende sagt genau das was
ich will dir zunächst einmal gerne der
frau brandner recht geben ich fand es
auch falsch dass die bundesregierung
sich darauf gedrückt so gut gezogen hat
vor einigen jahren das sei ein
privatwirtschaftlich investiertes
projekt wenn andere partner in europa
zum beispiel polen zum beispiel die
baltischen staaten erklären dass sie ein
politisches problem mit einer solchen
leitung haben dann muss die deutsche
bundesregierung das auch als politische
herausforderung an dem und muss in einen
dialog mit diesen partnern einsteigen
aber dieser dialog ist aus meiner sicht
von anfang an hoffnungslos gewesen weil
man uns als deutsche immer unterstellt
hat da hat ein feuer deutschland und bis
kanzler von euch interessen drin und die
meinung die er dazu habt ist keine
neutrale europapolitische sondern eine
eingefärbte und das ist das was mich
dabei beschwert aber wenn es tatsächlich
so ist wie frau brandt gesagt dass wir
dieses gas gar nicht brauchen dann
lassen sie es doch laufen dann sollen
doch diejenigen die diese leitung gebaut
haben an allen erster stelle gazprom und
an anderer stelle diejenigen die sich
auf dieses geschäft eingelassen haben
sollen sie doch den dass die
wirtschaftliche verantwortung das
wirtschaftliche risiko dieses projektes
tragen ich sehe nicht ein warum der
deutsche steuerzahler zum beispiel
entschädigen sollte wenn wir jetzt das
projekt verbieten und die unternehmen zu
recht sagen wir haben im vertrauen auf
die rechtslage
diese leitung gebaut wir wollen jetzt
unser geld zurück da finde ich es dass
deutsche steuerzahler geld zu schauen
aber es geht ja grundsätzlich darum wie
gehen wir mit russland um und wir haben
wir haben eine kanzlerin die bei dem
kreml kritiker
krankenhaus bett sitzt und ihnen hier
halt eben in die in der charité wird er
behandelt er hat ist gerade so dem tode
entronnen durch diesen giftanschlag und
auf der anderen seite haben wir eben
einen ehemaligen bundeskanzler der
gazprom bei gazprom aktiv ist und diese
pipeline fördert das ist doch er sah auf
einen sind doch zwei bilder wo man denkt
wie kriegt man das zusammen wir haben
diese proteste wie sollen wir denn unser
verhältnis zu russland wie sollen wir
das gestalten
also das ist in der tat dicke bretter
bohren aber ich glaube dass die signale
die das verhältnis zwischen deutschland
und russland ausmachen nicht von der
deutschen seite jetzt unbedingt die
negativen sind sondern es eigentlich auf
der russischen seite problematisch war
also hacker angriff auf den deutschen
bundestag vergiftung von der wahlen
tiergarten mord und solche dinge aber
das wäre doch wenn man das aber das wäre
doch alles das wäre doch alles gründe um
dann zu sagen da müssen wir jetzt auch
mal sagen das lassen wir nicht mehr und
wir sind ja auch dinge die folgen gehabt
haben im europäischen kontext von den
außenministern sind entsprechende
sanktionen auch beschlossen worden indem
man gesagt hat das ist mit uns nicht zu
machen
erstens verurteilen wir dass zweitens
belegen wir das mit sanktionen und
versuchen gleichzeitig den weg auf zu
machen wie man aus dieser misere wieder
miteinander rauskommt am ende sind wir
nachbarn wir haben eine gemeinsame
europäische geschichte um die haben auch
ein interesse an einen gemeinsame
friedliche zukunft im sinne unserer
kinder und deswegen müssen wir
miteinander im dialog sein und nicht den
starken mann markieren
was sind unsere interessen er verbrannt
und das vor darin welche interessen hat
deutschland in russland wir haben es
interesse an einer friedlichen
partnerschaft das haben wir und wir
haben das interesse in dieser situation
in der wir wunderbar sehen dass russland
nicht gleich putin ist und ich es
beeindruckend finde wie viele menschen
wirklich so mutig in die straße gehen an
die der seite dieser zivilgesellschaft
zu stehen oder ein zeichen zu setzen
wir haben keinerlei interesse daran uns
von putin mehr abhängig zu machen und
seinem system seinen korrupten system
und er sagt es ist eben so dass wenn wir
auf der einen seite eu sanktionen
mittragen die eine clique bestrafen und
andererseits dieser clique die
milliarden hinterher werfen mit nord
stream 2 dann ist es nicht besonders
konsequent und deswegen müssen wir
natürlich im dialog sein
wir müssen auch auf wenn dort geschäfte
zu machen wo es putin selber dient und
uns nur schade wir haben wirtschaftlich
nichts davon ist eine wette gegen klima
und vier spalten die jugend wir haben
nichts davon außer dass irgendwelche
leute wahrscheinlich davon gut
profitieren
wir wollten ja also ich würde gerne auch
das in großen linien sehen die
grundsatzfrage ist ja was für ein
verhältnis möchten wir mit unseren
europäischen nachbarn russland und ich
befürchte und bin auch besorgt darum
dass wir die nld schlittern wieder zu
einer neuen eiszeit zwischen deutschland
und russland und das wiedergewonnene
vertrauen gegenüber deutschland in
russland nach zwei weltkriegen und zwei
überfällen dass wir dieses vertrauen
verspielen und das sind größere
historische prozesse als jetzt eine
demonstration gegen korruption die man
natürlich unterstützt und die
niederschlagen dieser proteste auch
verurteilt aber wir müssen wirklich in
größeren dimensionen hier denken wir
haben ein bisschen frau daran was hatte
man im umgang mit moderner waldi zum
beispiel da gab es ja auch aus der
linken stimmen wo sie gesagt das ist
noch nicht ganz klar es ist erst muss
man bewiesen werden dass er wirklich
vergiftet worden ist von seiten des
kreml so gab es ja auch äußerungen die
ein bisschen irritiert haben nun ja ich
weiß ja nicht wie es bei ihnen aussieht
aber ich als mitglied des bundestages
und mitglied im auswärtigen ausschuss
habe bis heute keine beweise vorgelegt
bekommen von der bundesregierung über
die täterschaft ist es bisher unklar und
wir haben eine kleine anfrage gemacht
und außenpolitischer sprecher gregor
gysi hat eine kleine anfrage im fall
einer wahl nie an die bundesregierung
gestellt wo diese ganzen fragen wurden
unbeantwortet gelassen
aufgrund von staatsgeheimnissen weil man
staatsgeheimnis hüten möchte und da
fragen wir uns natürlich schon welche
deutschen staatsgeheimnisse werden hier
berührt ich meine es geht hier um das
hohe gut des informationspflicht der
informationspflicht der bundesregierung
gegenüber abgeordneten dem wird hier
nicht nachgegangen sondern wegen
staatsgeheimnissen wird einfach nicht
geantwortet das finde ich schon aber da
nochmal zum letztlich rund was ich sagen
wir haben eine geschichte der
entspannungs politik und ich sage ihnen
wir haben die letzten sechs bis sieben
jahre jetzt sanktionen gehabt die
deutsch-russische der deutsch russische
handel ist eingebrochen
die deutsche automobilindustrie ist
jetzt dabei über 50 prozent ihrer autos
nach china zu exportieren aufgrund
dieser aktion gegen die varus lang und
man muss ja einfach mal bilanzieren was
haben den sechs bis sieben jahre
sanktionen jetzt gebracht haben wir
russland tatsächlich dazu gebracht sich
anders zu verhalten in der innen- und
außenpolitik wie wir es mit diesen
sanktionen erzielen wolken oder haben
wir letztendlich schlechtere beziehungen
und da sage ich diese sanktionen haben
nichts gebracht außer sharp will die
eigene wirtschaft bei den usa profitiert
gerade davon
und ja man merke ich habe also fragen
während den usa gegen austin 24 sturm
läuft sind sie dabei dieses russische
erdöl in die usa um 40 prozent zu
steigern der import bleiben wir noch mal
kurz bei dieser frage der herner weil
nicht er hat sie wollten da gerne was zu
sagen also diese frage von wie wie geht
man da jetzt und man was benutzt was
bewirken denn die sanktion fest können
sie da auch direkt was zu sagen also zum
ersten möchte ich feststellen dass wir
zum thema weil die natürlich nicht mehr
deutsche alleinige meinung haben sondern
es gibt die organisation die das verbots
abkommen zu den chemie machen überwacht
die hat die groben erprobt also da gibt
es ein genaues verfahren abgeben und
stöße gegen dieses abkommen ermittelt
werden und dann gibt es gemäss vertrag
eben mitwirkungspflichten des jeweiligen
landes in dem das aufgetreten ist in
diesem fall russland und russland
weigert sich diese mitwirkungspflicht
nachzukommen und zweige hat sich auch
maßnahmen zu ergreifen um zu verhindern
dass dieser giftstoff der ja objektiv in
russland in irgendeiner weise vorhanden
ist demnach zu gehen und den zu
vernichten und deswegen haben wir nicht
nur wir sondern viele staaten dieser
erde die verantwortlichen personen in
russland mit sanktionen belegt ich
möchte nur einen punkt anknüpfen also
ich möchte bitte liegt dass hier hin und
eifer wechselt wird ja dass wir ein
schlechtes verhältnis zu russland haben
war damit zu tun dass präsident putin
der verzweifelte derzeit in der russland
raus ist aus der sozialistischen
planwirtschaft die verantwortung für das
die entwicklung in dem lande trägt eine
ziemlich lausige gesellschaftspolitische
ökonomische infrastrukturelle bilanz
vorzulegen hat er hat viele jahre lang
große gewinne aus öl und gas einnahmen
aus dem besten gehabt und hat dieses
geld eben nicht verwendet um damit das
land zu der welt sie verzieren
unabhängig zu machen von den öl- und
gaseinnahmen die wirtschaft zu
entwickeln die die infrastruktur zu
entwickeln universitäten zu bauen und so
fort er hat dieses geld verplempert in
dem er unter anderem seine oligarchen
gefüttert hat die arminia der und multi
milliardär geworden sind und sich in den
fußballverein der westlichen welt
eingekauft haben und das ist halt
schlicht und einfach ein verhalten eines
despoten aus dem morgenland und das ist
das größte problem weißrussland hat
russland hat nicht das problem dass wir
irgendwie ärger mit dem wollen sondern
dass dieser präsident das land nicht an
die schotten ihnen die chancen
vorenthält sich entsprechend
ich freue mich dass mehr menschen in
russland sind die sanktionen wie würden
sie es dann bewerten hat das vor allem
ding unserer wirtschaft geschadet oder
hat das etwas gebracht im verhältnis zu
russland man kann ja man könnte ja frau
da die umfragen sagen es hat die das
feld ist vor allen dingen erst mal nur
verschlechtert also es hat eine einreise
schon vor einiger zeit schon das war
nach den sanktionen wegen kind und ost
ukraine eine reise einer
wirtschaftsdelegation dass bayern mit
dem damaligen ministerpräsident nach
moskau gegeben wo auch einzelne mit der
delegation aus der politischen ebene ein
früherer ministerpräsident was glaube
ich vorgetragen hat also die sanktionen
seien ja schlecht für die wirtschaft und
dann hat er ein vertreter der
bayerischen wirtschaft gesagt das größte
problem das wir haben ist nicht sind
nicht die sanktionen das größte problem
ist der verfall des opel kurses und dass
die russische wirtschaft ebenso schlecht
darstellt dass der dass der handel und
wandel mit russland nicht prosperieren
test ich finde das ist eine klare ansage
an die adresse platini protein c es
versäumt hat dieses land entwickelt für
mich weiß er dass in kürze die menschen
in russland sagen werden der kaiser hat
ja keine kleider an und dass sie dann
auch die frage stellen werden wie konnte
es eigentlich sein dass die ganze welt
sich im 21 jahrhundert prosperieren
entwickelt russland hat ständig konflikt
mit außen und innen im inneren in der
inneren entwicklung kommt nichts
zustande
da legt er den finger in die wunde er
sagte ja groß land genau sagen wie bei
uns ja das ist es ist putin in dem fall
einfach das problem
ich würde das thema gerne and
personalisieren wenn sie erlauben und
ihre interessante frage nochmal
aufgreifen mit der langen langen linie
was denn eigentlich die lange linie
dabei ist also russland hat genau wie
die länder zentralasiens enorme
potenziale an erneuerbaren energien
riesige potenziale mehr als 1000 mal
mehr installierte kapazität für wind
onshore als wir in deutschland
installiert haben im moment und durch
eine mit anleitung kann man auch erdgas
kann man auch wasserstoff transportieren
mit russland zusammen über die nächsten
jahrzehnte können wir die klima- und
energiepolitischen fragestellungen des
ganzen kontinentes lösen und diese
chancen und diese perspektiven würde ich
gerne aufgreifen ich würde gern auch mal
die satt sehen dass das öl der zukunft
wasserstoff ist und fallenden grüner
wasserstoff ist um gemeinsam sozusagen
einen herausforderer als einen guten
taten da sehe ich russland als einen
eminent wichtigen partner auch und ich
sehe auch die industriepolitischen
potenziale da drin auf russischer seite
das als sinnvoll zu erachten und
sozusagen im gemeinsamen weg dann auch
die dinge ansprechen zu dürfen die nicht
in ordnung sind ganz klein auch mit
einem russland in dem so wie am
vergangenen wochenende demonstranten
zusammengeprügelt werden verhaftet
werden das ist natürlich zu verurteilen
überhaupt gar keine frage das ist ja in
dieser runde auch schon deutlich gemacht
worden das habe ich auch gemacht
so geht man mit friedlichen
demonstranten nicht um das im übrigen
auch ein verstoß gegen internationale
verpflichtungen von russland trotzdem
müssen wir ja miteinander gucken wie
kriegen wir es eigentlich hin dass wir
gemeinsam in verbindung bleiben und wenn
wir wirtschaftlichen verbindungen sind
können wir auch solche themen anspricht
frau brenner ist das nicht ein argument
wenn man sagt wenn wir es schaffen zum
beispiel eine zukunftstechnologie auch
damen gemeinsam hin zu bekommen und zu
sagen es ist doch viel sinnvoller wenn
wir da eine pipeline zusammen betreiben
damit wir unsere gemeinsame
energiepolitik haben als dass wir gar
keinen kontakt miteinander haben und
dann irgend gar keinen einfluss mehr auf
keiner ist hier gegen kooperation mit
russischen wirtschaftlichen akteuren wir
sind hier präzise gegen eine pipeline
die mit gazprom gebaut wird die nur
deutschland russland betrifft gegen
unsere europäischen partner für gas
fossile energieträger was wir
diskutieren könnten wäre ob wir
gemeinsam europäisch wenn wir über neue
energie partnerschaften nachdenken
welche rolle dann unsere europäischen
nachbarn spielen das hat man ganz
anderer ansatz her sagt hof als eine
pipeline gegen den willen und
europäischer partner durchzudrücken in
einem fuß im sektor den wir nicht mehr
brauchen es in milliarden versenkt für
den klimaschutz
und wenn sie mir glauben zur frau
datenströme blick auf russland und die
frage ihres verhältnisses zu putin ja da
wissen wir wie schwierig das ist dann
muss man auf syrien gucken und wie sie
dastehen zufahrt und was in syrien
passiert ist muss ich mir an der stelle
erlauben weil sie machen auch permanent
vergleiche und die sanktionen weil er
hat es nicht sauber beantwortet hat wir
würden gar nicht würde mal gerne wissen
wo wir wären heute mit blick auf die
ukraine ohne eu sanktionen ich glaube es
wäre wesentlich schwieriger und
schlechter vor ort wenn die eu keine
sanktionen damals erlassen hätte und
deswegen sind ja auch immer noch richtig
und notwendig und ich finde es schwierig
immer nur zu sagen wir sind diejenigen
die ihren konflikt rhein treiben wer ist
denn wer sind denn diejenigen die
nationale grenzen überschreiten wir sind
diejenigen die menschen ins gefängnis
stecken und fordern das sind doch nicht
wir
und deswegen muss man das noch mal in
die perspektive setzen und sagen darum
geht es und die frage ob wir dazu als
europäer eine gemeinsame haltung finden
kann man aber auch sagen russland ist
ein unabhängiges land das kann das so
machen wir können müssen uns nicht in
die inneren angelegenheiten einmischen
dann müssen wir aber auch keine
partnerschaften und kein geld an die
oligarchen zahlen die dieses system
unterstützen
da haben wir schon eine verantwortung
dafür weil das ist schließlich unser
steuerzahler geld um mit dem möchte ich
dann nicht auch noch solche kollegen
werden doch bewiesen dass wir gemeinsame
europäische antworten hinbekommen das
ist jetzt nicht die frage verbrannt
worden da denn sie wollten jetzt noch
mal kurz was zu sagen ja also ich wurde
ja direkt angesprochen und wurde ja
etwas eine steile these hier
angetan also ich möchte ihnen frau
brandner versichern ich habe keinerlei
verhältnis zu herzen gehen oder auch der
söhne im verhältnis
ich glaub mal erich franz meinte wenn
das schon hier so behauptet wird ich
stehe zu keinem verhältnis zu dieser
regierung wenig in russland wäre dann
wäre ich in der linken opposition gegen
diesen organischen kapitalismus und
gegen diese korruption und würde
wahrscheinlich auch verhaftet werden und
insofern erhalte ich dass wir wirklich
und seriös und unredlich von ihnen was
ich aber allerdings sagen möchte ist
dass ich unseriös und unredlich finde
dass man einerseits eine menschenrechts
orientierte außenpolitik machen möchte
und den handel
die handelspolitik davon abhängig machen
möchte aber diese maßstäbe diese
doppelten standards quasi nur bei
russland zum prinzip erklärt aber nicht
beispielsweise gegenüber saudi arabien
als gehört dass man handeln einstudieren
soll
ich habe ihn als gehört dass man den
handel mit der türkei einstellen sollen
oder mit anderen autokratien mit denen
wir handel betreiben
und ich warne auch davor ich habe immer
bei jeder kritik die ich gegenüber
anderen ländern habe habe ich immer
gesagt ich lehne wirtschaftssanktionen
ab weil ihr wohnheim hatte die hiesige
bevölkerung dort trifft und ich möchte
auch davon ahnen dass wir unsere
handelspolitik jetzt unter diesem
gesichtspunkt wirklich ausrichten
ok des campus stapel bitteschön beziehen
mitgehen möchten wir reden oder der
poker ist klar dass sie sagen diese
aktion halten sie nicht halten sie nicht
für sinnvoll ich würde mal gerne auch
mal ein bisschen nach vorne schauen weil
wir haben jetzt einen neuen
amerikanischen präsidenten hat sie waren
vorher auch koordinator für die
transatlantische zusammenarbeit jetzt
ist der druck aus den usa groß dieses
projekt also das projekt nicht weiter
laufen zu lassen ist die frage oder
haben sehen sie da eine möglichkeit dass
man da ins gespräch kam unter tampa das
ganz klar eine forderung dass man dass
man aus wien beenden sollte es gab die
drohung von sanktionen gegenüber
deutschen firmen die beteiligt waren
wer wie sehen sie denn die usa in diesem
verhältnis jetzt russland deutschland
also zunächst einmal glaube ich dass wir
mit joe biden einen amerikanischen
präsidenten haben der im gegensatz zu
seinem amtsvorgänger an gemeinsamen
konstruktiven lösungen für die themen
die auf der transatlantischen agenda
liegen wirklich sucht und das ja auch
daran glaubt dass wir lösungen finden
können sein vorgänger hat uns ja immer
als die männer gebraucht also wenn wir
mit donald trump irgend eine einigung
hinbekommen hätten hätte er sie
möglicherweise allein deshalb nicht
gemacht weil er gegenüber seinen
wählerinnen und wählern im mittleren
westen der vereinigten staaten von
amerika dann dieses bild aufgegeben
hätte alles böse was amerika geschieht
kommt aus europa aus deutschland aus
china aus russland das wird deswegen
wird sich die situation mit joe biden
grundlegend verändern weil wir wieder
ins gespräch kommen wir über diese
themen ich würde dem amerikanischen
präsidenten wenn man mich fragen würde
anbieten das waren als europäer sagt
jawohl wir wollen einen intensiveren
dialog über die frage der
energiesicherheit führen wir wollen auch
eine die frage beantworten wie können
wir sicherstellen dass wir nicht
abhängig sind von einseitigen
energiequelle
das ist natürlich ein thema was klar
auch russland anspricht aber nicht
ausschließlich russland auch die
flüssiggas terminals haben einen sinn
ich habe vor zwei jahren wird der
damaligen noch präsidentin von litauen
gesprochen
die hat zu mir gesagt wir haben ein
flüssiggasterminal das gas was da kommt
brauchen wir eigentlich gar nicht da
kommt auch so gut wie kein gas aber sie
können sich nicht vorstellen wie einfach
die verhandlungen mit dem russischen
gaslieferanten geworden sind seit wir
diesen termin haben und ihnen sagen
konnten zwei können wir anders bedient
also was die sicherheit angeht muss man
redundanzen haben und da braucht es
meines erachtens eine europäische und
eine transatlantische verständigung und
im rahmen dieses konzept wie kommen wir
dazu dass wir uns nicht ein zu einseitig
und auf dauer abhängig machen von einer
quelle im buchstäblich im sinne was die
energie angeht in diesem dialog würde
ich die amerikaner gerne voll mit
einbeziehen und dann wird am ende dabei
herauskommen
in welcher weise das einfluss hat auf
uns vor russischen gas- und ölgeschäft
im übrigen dann allerdings auch auf die
geschäfte die die amerikaner mit mit mit
russland bei bayern machen und wenn wir
dieses dialog angebot auf den tisch
legen glaube ich können wir auch
erreichen dass diese einseitige
fixierung auf diese extra territorialen
st
gegen das team 2 die auch rechtswidrig
sind und deswegen zurückweisen
das wird die überwinden können ok also
ein positives hoffnungszeichen
würden sie das auch oder wo sehen sie
die möglichkeiten der usa in diesem auch
in diesem verhältnis zu europa und
russland also wo ist die buddhisten
position da also ich kann absolut die
meinung ich finde es auch richtig die
argumentation der amerikanischen seite
aufzunehmen und zu sagen gut wenn euch
wirklich daran gelegen ist dass europa
nicht zu abhängig von der energie seite
her von russland ist dann lass uns das
mal in einem globalen kontext betrachten
lasst uns mal gucken wie die
abhängigkeit des nordamerikanischen
kontinents vom erdöl russlands ist lass
uns mal gucken wie wir miteinander
vielleicht auch in ein multinationales
abkommen hineinkommen in dem direkte
abhängigkeiten verloren gehen sie haben
auf europäischer seite eigentlich eine
große abhängigkeit mehr als 20 prozent
unseres erdgases kommen aus den
niederlanden und niemand hat damit
gerechnet dass wir innerhalb von fünf
jahren diese quelle endgültig nicht
erschlossen haben so wir haben jetzt
noch norwegisches gas und die norweger
überlegen in die arktis zu gehen können
sie frau war ja noch mal sagen ob sie
das so gut finden aus einer ökologischen
perspektive heraus und über
energiequellen zu reden vor allen dingen
wo sind die potenziale der erneuerbaren
energiequellen ist in einem
multinationalen kontext absolut richtig
dann aber auf gleicher augenhöhe alle
miteinander und nicht mit
sanktionsdrohungen
wenn es funktionieren könnte also dass
wichtige finde ich wenn man in die
gespräche eintritt ist dass man erst mal
sagt die sanktionen müssten
zurückgenommen werden weil es zwischen
partnern handelt man nicht mit
sanktionen und dann muss man sich ein
gemeinsames positives ziel setzen das
ist natürlich energiesicherheit aber
auch klimaschutz und dann sagen wir eben
weg mit tracking weg mit 0 2 und wir
investieren gemeinsam transatlantisch in
erneuerbare in grünen wasserstoff in die
technologien die wir brauchen für
energieeffizienz etc da können wir
gemeinsam projekte zusammen auf den weg
bringen klimaneutralen handel weil
natürlich handeln nie neutral ist
sondern immer auch etwas voranbringen
kann
das sind jetzt die schritte die wir mit
den beiden administrationen voranbringen
können ich finde sind große
möglichkeiten wenn die jetzt sagen wir
sind bereit etwas zu ändern ihr bitte
aber auch und dafür haben jetzt ein
gemeinsames ziel das ist aber dass auf
augenhöhe
langfristiges ziel ich würde dann jetzt
die letzten man nicht mal schnell
angehen das ist dann umgesetzt wird noch
zum 2 ich würde jetzt gerne mal schauen
auf die frage der zivilgesellschaft und
das ist ja auch ihre aufgabe herz auf
wenn man wir haben diese demonstrationen
gesehen
wir sehen da da geht etwas in russland
da sind eine menge leute bereit auf die
straße zu gehen obwohl sie wissen dass
sie verhaftet werden können wir an der
wahl nie ist noch in haft
er sei wie können sie denn die
zivilgesellschaft stärken also das
machen wir durch zum beispiel
förderprogramme in den
zivilgesellschaftliche begegnungen
möglich sind leider leiden die auch sehr
unter den cupid bedingungen das muss man
einfach sagen aber die bundesregierung
wendet 22 millionen euro auf um in den
ländern der östlichen partnerschaft und
in russland zivilgesellschaftliche
projekte zu fördern also städte
begegnungsstätte austausche
jugendaustausch als solche dinge von
daher versuchen wir schon diese kontakte
aufrechtzuerhalten aber wir laufen sie
noch genug druck aber das ist ja nicht
dafür gedacht um druck aufzubauen
sondern es dafür gedacht dass menschen
sich begegnen unterhalb des
diplomatischen levels die verbindung
zweier länder ist mehr als nur die
diplomatische ebene sondern sind ja die
verbindung der menschen untereinander
wenn man sich vertraut wenn man sich mit
dem herzen sieht würde ich jetzt mal so
sagen und das ist meine aufgabe diese
verbindungen sicher zu stellen und dafür
zu sorgen dass die menschen sich
vertrauen auf der ebene und merken dass
es auch menschen sind auf der anderen
seite der grenze und gemeinsam es sich
lohnt ziele zu entwickeln
frau darin wie kann man die
demokratiebewegung in russland stützen
zumindest muss man sich fragen ob die
letzten jahre die politik deutschlands
und der eu mit dazu geführt haben dass
die demokratiebewegungen stärker
geworden ist oder eben auch
demokratische oppositionsbewegung da
gefördert worden ist mir macht sorgen
dass die stimmung in der gesellschaft in
russland zunehmend anti-westliche wird
und zunehmend nationalistisch wert das
zeigen alle umfragen und studien und
platzeck vom deutsch russischen forum
hat das auch noch mal bestätigt das
macht mir schon sorge und deshalb würde
ich gerne dafür plädieren weil sie mich
da bei der letzten frage umgangen haben
also ich würde schon dafür plädieren
dass wir schauen dass wir bessere
beziehungen haben dass wir als ein teil
europas uns nicht abhängig machen
in treue zu den transatlantiker
washington sondern gucken was sind die
interessen der europäischen bürgerinnen
und bürger was ist das europa was mit
teil als russland quasi dieses europas
wie müssen wir hier das gemeinsame haus
europa aufbauen und ich bin da auch
nicht nur in der tradition von gerhard
schröder weil er immer hier angeführten
ist auch die tradition von konrad
adenauer der nach moskau gereist ist um
die kriegsgefangenen heim zu holen ist
hier aber der leser einschränken her
können wir aber deshalb trotzdem noch
ein gutes transatlantisches verhältnis
gepflegt hat aber frau dahlem so ganz
ist es glaube ich mich zu verständlich
warum sie dann
man kann ja sowohl mit unser ziel ist
doch nur sowohl mit den usa als auch mit
den russen ein gutes verhältnis dabei
da es sich für essen der usa also vor
diesen karren spannen zu lassen und
diese konfrontationspolitik mit russland
zu befördern ist nicht im interesse der
bürgerinnen und bürger europa okay er
hat mir auch wenn wir auf diese bewegung
die die proteste jetzt schauen in
russland und dann wenn wir dann auch
noch auf diese person navalny schauen
ist es der richtige wie würden sie ihn
wo würden sie ihn sehen ist er derjenige
der wirklich da eine eine bewegung denn
anführen kann jetzt im moment muss es im
achter seine frau natürlich auch also
wenn er jetzt noch in haft ist die frage
ist weil es wurde ja auch eine zeitlang
wurde gesagt dass er auch ja ein sehr
starker populist ist wie gesagt er wäre
ein nationalist wie würden sie in der
einschätzen
ich glaube das ist in russland eine
ganze reihe von menschen und auch und
erwachsene zahlen von menschen die
bringt der generation der mittdreißiger
bis mittvierziger also der zukünftigen
generation des landes gibt die in
opposition zu putin stehen und die
missstände im land offen anprangern und
da gibt es ja leider genügend
navalny ist zum symbol dieser opposition
geworden weil dazu gemacht hat also
durch den giftanschlag und die
verschleierung politik die die russische
regierung um diesen anschlag herum
gemacht hat bis hin zu dem was jetzt die
letzten tage passiert ist mit seiner
verhaftung mit der niederknüppeln der
demonstration am vergangenen wochenende
hat putin letztlich selbst in der weise
zu gesicht und zum zum haupt dieser
oppositionsbewegung gemacht und ich kann
mir schon vorstellen dass daraus noch
etwas wird
ich glaube dass im blick auf die
entwicklung in russland wie gesellschaft
wir den auftrag haben dass wir klar
sagen dass wir in der seite von freiheit
rechtsstaatlichkeit und demokratie
stehen dass wir auch durch unsere
möglichkeiten dafür sorgen dass die
notwendige transparenz und die
medienöffentlichkeit da ist die dinge
auch so zu nennen sie zu benennen sind
weil ja in russland selbst die medien
zunehmend unterdrückt die freie
berichterstattung massiv unterdrückt
wird und die medien gleichgeschaltet
sind und die vorstellung dass es
irgendwie besser wäre wenn wir das
alleine machen als deutsch oder europa
und amerika die würde ich dann doch
zurückweisen ich glaube wenn wir uns mit
unserem werte fahrer usa in dieser frage
gut koordinieren und abstimmen und eine
gemeinsame antwort auf diese fragen
finden dann sind wir stark und stärker
und dann wird im zweifel auch unsere
ausgestreckte hand zum dialog und zur
partnerschaft mit russland die er das
russische volk erreichen soll
glaubwürdiger angenommen als wenn wir da
unser eigenes ding in einer art
schaukelpolitik wohl gesagt hätte
zwischen russland und dem westen
trainer sollten wir alex alexej nawalny
richtig unterstützen und seine bewegung
sollte man das tun
es geht nicht darum den einen oder den
anderen akteur zu unterstützen sondern
es geht darum die forderung nach einem
rechtsstaat ganz klar aufrecht zu
erhalten und es geht mir auch nicht
darum ob er einer weile gut oder
schlecht ist sondern es geht darum dass
versucht wurde diese menschen zu
ermorden dass er jetzt in haft ist auf
grundlage eines urteils dass der
europäische menschengerichtshof als
eindeutig politisch beurteilt hat und
dass er jetzt 3000 über 3000 menschen am
wochenende in haft genommen wurden das
ist der punkt und wir müssen an der
seite all jener stehen die für
rechtsstaatlichkeit kämpfen die gegen
korruption sich einsetzen und es ist
aufwendig das immer wieder das argument
kommt dass die gegner putins dass die
dann alle nationalisten sein das war in
der ukraine so dass es jetzt wieder so
das ist irgendwie auffällig das einzige
argument ist was den leuten ein feld das
design nationalisten weil sie irgendwie
glauben dass es bei uns zieht das ist
sehr fadenscheinig aber ich glaube dass
ich wie ich finde es wirklich wichtig
dass man da auf deutsch machen die hand
auf hand ist ja navalny der von
migranten als kakerlaken spricht ist er
in ihren augen ein demokrat oder ein
nationalist ich habe es gerade sehr
deutlich gesagt dass es mir gar nicht
darum geht ob er gut oder schlecht oder
wie auch immer ist sondern dass er und
wie jeder andere mensch das recht auf
ein faires verfahren hat genau wie die
anderen nutzer auch und dann aber
kämpfen wir uns an dieser seite stehen
wir und da möchte ich auch wirklich
dafür plädieren dass wir den austausch
auf der bürgerinnen eben verstärken über
unsere stiftungen über
städtepartnerschaften dass wir da
wesentlich mehr investieren und dass die
bürgerinnen die jetzt demonstrieren die
so viel mut haben ja es sind ganz viele
die noch nie demonstriert haben dass die
auch ein zeichen von uns bekommen dass
wir das wahrnehmen dass wir das das wird
es auch an der seite derjenigen stehen
die für rechtsstaatlichkeit und
demokratie demonstrieren
wir haben noch einkommen werden ganz
kurz noch mal ein kleiner nur darauf
hinweisen dass die liberalen ja wir
müssen ja auch die alternativen im
russland im blick haben leider ist es ja
so dass die liberalen gerade mal bei den
umfragen russland unter fünf prozent
sind die alternative im moment sind oder
die von ängsten oder die nationalisten
jetzt sollte man schon okay fordern
vielen dank vielen dank frau den vielen
dank herr hardt vielen dank frau
prantner und herr sator für diese runde
über russland morgen gibt es auch wieder
eine phoenix runde dann schauen wir mal
wieder zu auf das thema corona der frust
im corona lockdown wächst ja aber wir
wollen noch mal wissen was ist dann mit
einer anderen
einer längerfristigen strategie ich
hoffe sie sind dabei schönen abend bei
phoenix jetzt folgt der tag